cuál ha sido la mayor lección que te ha
dejado la pandemia pregunta difícil sin
duda sobre todo pensando que ésta aún no
termina y que nos ha enseñado más como
humanidad que muchos otros eventos
como profesor me gusta hacerme este tipo
de preguntas para poder llevarle un
mejor aprendizaje a los estudiantes no
cabe duda que en este tiempo como nunca
hemos tenido que hacernos preguntas
sobre nuestra disciplina la educación
por todos los cambios que ha tenido que
experimentar
y es que podemos coincidir en que
estamos en un momento histórico de la
educación casi tan trascendente como las
primeras escuelas en grecia o cuando me
gramos del he's a las presentaciones
sólo que quien iba a decir que el
próximo gran episodio de la historia de
la educación sino escribir en nuestras
salas o nuestras habitaciones
todavía queda mucho que aprender pero
los primeros pasos que hemos vivido
estos meses sin duda nos están ya dando
una gran lección
muy buenos días tardes o noches mi
nombre es isaac profesor isaac y hoy
vengo a conversar con ustedes sobre la
gran lección que la pandemia le está
dejando a la educación cuando yo era
niño el mejor momento del día era sin
duda la escuela yo no lo sabía pero
mientras la maestra nos hablaba y jugaba
con mis compañeros
estábamos aprendiendo y de alguna forma
esto y va modelando nuestra forma de ver
el mundo
años después ahora que soy profesor y
estoy del otro lado del salón me doy
cuenta que este va a ser un privilegio
que no va a ser igual para todas las
generaciones
esto porque a partir de marzo del 2020
cuando cerraron las escuelas comenzó un
nuevo episodio de esta historia
solo en méxico más de 36 millones de
estudiantes tuvieron que dejar las aulas
presenciales de un día para otro
comenzando la que sería considerada la
peor crisis educativa de la historia
contemporánea
incluso el director de educación del
banco mundial doctor jaime saavedra
consideró que las pérdidas por atrasarse
en la escuela abandono y planes
educativos fallidos
representaría aproximadamente
perder 10 trillones de dólares en los
sistemas educativos de todo el mundo
décadas de monitoreo y evaluación
sirvieron de poco en el momento en el
que las escuelas dejaron de ser un lugar
seguro para los estudiantes
y no cabe duda que todos nos
preguntábamos qué iba a suceder
pero no todo fueron malas noticias
algunas escuelas y sistemas educativos
no tardaron en adaptarse comenzando a
escribir las nuevas páginas de este
capítulo con resultados sin duda muy
variados y es que la opinión general
podría decir que para dar educación a
distancia
solamente basta con tomar los contenidos
de la presencial y cambiarlos de formato
pero es justo aquí donde en la opinión
de este profesor que tuvo que aprender
junto con muchos las argucias de la
tecnología para darle la mejor
experiencia a sus estudiantes que
comenzó la verdadera gran lección
para no tener un punto de vista parcial
y único me dedique durante los últimos
meses a conversar con profesores y
estudiantes que habían estado en el
frente de batalla
me di cuenta de que estos tenían grandes
experiencias y grandes historias de lo
que habían vivido en esos últimos meses
la generación de profesores estudiantes
que vivieron esto tiene varios nombres
de acuerdo a académicos y a la opinión
pública algunos los llaman la generación
de z después de su esto por la adopción
de esta popular plataforma para dar
clases virtuales otros los llaman la
generación perdida por las horas de
clase que ya no podrán recuperar a mí el
nombre más apropiado para ellos me
parece la generación pandemia que son
estudiantes y profesores que se
adaptaron a pesar de todo durante la
pandemia para continuar con su educación
conversando con ellos y ellas los
pandemias
me di cuenta de que había grandes
experiencias y grandes historias en la
adaptación educativa
sin embargo esta variedad hacía muy
complejo saber una sola forma de abordar
esta realidad
pero me di cuenta de que
independientemente del nivel educativo
la plataforma o la materia que se
estuviera enseñando en general hubo tres
situaciones que todos mencionaron como
grandes retos instituciones que
consisten en el exceso de contenido la
falta de contexto y la escasa
socialización a continuación voy a
explicarte cada una de ellas cuando las
escuelas se dieron cuenta de que les
quedaba muy poco tiempo para cubrir sus
programas algunas decidieron enseñar la
mayor cantidad de temas en la menor
cantidad de tiempo ocasionando así una
gran cantidad de frustración en
estudiantes que decían que ni siquiera
en la educación ac es decir la educación
antes del cobat aprendían de una forma
tan acelerada
incluso algunos reportajes como uno
publicado por el periódico del país en
abril del 2020
sostenía que 6 de cada 10 estudiantes
entrevistados
tenían más estrés por la escuela que por
la pandemia
la falta de contexto ocurrió
principalmente porque
todos asumimos que el estudiante tenía
una realidad muy similar a la de su
escuela en su respectivo hogar
quienes miramos a las videoconferencias
asumimos que los estudiantes tenían un
buen equipo de cómputo y una conexión de
internet adecuada quienes migramos a la
educación por televisión o en radio
asumimos que el estudiante tenía la
infraestructura correcta y el equipo
para dar seguimiento a sus clases y de
forma generalizada asumimos que los
estudiantes tenían el espacio y la
seguridad psicológica en su casa para
continuar su escuela de la misma manera
pero en zonas tan complicadas como lo es
méxico e incluso toda latinoamérica
donde la diversificación social es tan
amplia y la brecha digital tan compleja
esto dista de representar una sola
realidad
finalmente la escasa socialización se
dio porque
ignoramos que muchas personas tienen sus
primeros contactos sociales a través de
la escuela
y que para muchos la escuela no es lo
que ocurre en las aulas sino lo que
ocurre antes y después de ellas
las pláticas de pasillo las
conversaciones antes de empezar la clase
lo que ocurre en el patio todo
desapareció de un día para otro y ni
siquiera con todos los avances
tecnológicos que tenemos hay una forma
eficaz de sustituir todo esto que hacer
y definir los problemas es tan complejo
cómo tratar de darles una solución mi
propuesta es sencilla
escuchar a los pan de miel porque nadie
como quien ha conocido el reto como para
dar luz de cómo resolverlo a
continuación quiero darte tres
sugerencias que he desarrollado a raíz
de los diálogos que he tenido con ellos
aclarando que no se trata de una receta
de cocina ni de un instructivo pues
éstas solamente son tres propuestas que
se pueden tomar como unos primeros pasos
para comenzar esta nueva etapa
en primer lugar con respecto al exceso
de contenido se recomienda poner la
motivación sobre la información
a qué me refiero la motivación siempre
fue un activo principal en la educación
por un lado porque sin esta los
estudiantes no ponen atención y porque
por otro lado los estudiantes sin esta
no se quedan en la escuela
pero ahora que los riesgos son más altos
para dejar a los estudios
tener la motivación como un punto clave
puede ser una gran respuesta una
estudiante me decía el otro día la mayor
parte de lo que yo estudio en sus clases
lo puede encontrar en internet pero lo
que me gusta de sus clases es que me
mantienen motivada a seguir aprendiendo
como podemos encontrar esta motivación
en nuestros estudiantes cómo podemos
motivarnos a nosotros mismos a buscar
esta respuesta y cómo puedo motivarnos
como sociedad a tener los ojos puestos
sobre este tipo de preguntas
respecto a la falta de contexto la
recomendación es migrar a un aprendizaje
100% basado en el contexto
durante años estuvimos entrenando a
nuestros estudiantes para un futuro que
ahora desconocemos
esta descontextualización ahora encontró
un punto crítico un maestro de
informática me comentaba el otro día me
siento muy frustrado de tener que
enseñarle a mis estudiantes un programa
de computación donde el salón de clases
a más de la mitad no tiene computadora
me gustaría continuar el maestro me
gustaría poder adaptar mi programa para
que sin descuidar los contenidos yo
pueda enseñarle a los alumnos algo que
les sirva y puedan aplicar el día de hoy
como podríamos como sistemas educativos
adaptar los programas para que sean
aplicables el mismo día que se enseñan y
cómo podemos cambiar el formato de
nuestra educación para que sirva para el
día de hoy y no para un futuro que
apenas se alcanza a dibujar en el
horizonte
finalmente respecto a la escasa
socialización voy a contarles una
pequeña historia
al principio del semestre uno de mis
estudiantes me comentó que su momento
favorito del día eran los 5 minutos
antes de clase porque esto servía para
que ellos se pusieran en contacto para
que ellos se pusieron al tanto de sus
vidas para que se relajaron antes de
empezar la clase
por esto decidí comenzar a dejar 5 o 6
minutos antes de algunas clases abriendo
la plataforma virtual y permitía que
ellos dialogarán entre sí mi sorpresa
fue que un día llegando después de esos
cinco minutos me encontré con esto
al principio reaccione pensando que se
trataba de una broma pero luego entendí
que había algo más ocurriendo en esta
escena
les pregunté cómo había ocurrido y me di
cuenta de que había requerido una gran
cantidad de organización de comunicación
de construcción social
y cuando nos pregunten cuánto tiempo les
había tomado me dijeron que solamente
cinco minutos antes de empezar la clase
con esto entendí la importancia de que
los estudiantes tengan espacios para
constituirse como sociedad porque hoy se
organizan para divertirse pero mañana
podrían estarse organizando para hacer
de su sociedad un lugar mejor y por esto
la recomendación para la falta de
socialización sería que tengamos
actividades en nuestras clases que
busquen la edificación social porque
solamente si permitimos a los
estudiantes conocerse y aprender entre
sí es que podemos luego prepararlos para
conocerse y aprender como una nueva
sociedad
sin embargo qué podemos hacer para que
esto sea parte activa de nuestra
educación y para que esto no incluye
exclusivamente a profesores y alumnos
sino además a padres madres de familia y
otros miembros activos de nuestra
comunidad
como pueden ver la mayor parte de estas
recomendaciones son más preguntas que
respuestas y esto es porque la pandemia
si algo nos ha enseñado es que todos nos
hemos vuelto principiantes de nuevo en
esta disciplina
pero la ventaja de esto es que nos hemos
dado cuenta de que ahora más que nunca
la educación la podemos hacer todos y
que en los próximos grandes episodios de
nuestra disciplina pueden estar al
alcance de una maestra innovadora de un
estudiante curioso o de una comunidad
activa y consciente porque la gran
lección que la pandemia me ha dejado a
mí como educador como profesor como
estudiante y como miembro de mi
comunidad es que la educación no debe
ser una preparación para la vida la
educación es la vida misma muchas
gracias y que tengan un excelente
[Aplausos]